first of all I feel blessed lucky to be
one of the survivors of you know what
people what my experience was the war on
cannabis so when you tap back in the
historical roots there have been people
who have stood up and helped redefine
the social policy in the legal policy of
cannabis and many of us have suffered
cannabis does have medicinal value it
can intervene in a number of different
symptom clusters that we have why isn't
there a medical advisory board to the
Bureau of cannabis control my right and
the rights of my fellow citizens to have
access to all of those resources right
should not be unduly repressed by a
minority that chooses to remain ignorant
and afraid the cannabis culture is one
of being a socially responsible member
of the community it's really a
difference of whether or not you're in
it for the money or you want to change
the world boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation we are still at
new West Summit the world's leading
cannabis tech conference we are now
sitting down with granddaddy Mike hey
folks hey thank you thanks for inviting
me I'm flattered and I'm super excited
because granddaddy Mike has 52 years
with granddaddy Mike unlimited and he's
been building up within the cannabis
industry for that long and this is these
are really important perspectives
because they are right there with all of
the variables of the evolution of what's
been happening and so as you paper right
now and I'm really excited for you to
teach us about this the first thing that
I kind of want to talk about with you is
that the what have been some of the most
fascinating sort of shifts highs lows
the troughs along the last 52 years of
the journey of cannabis well
first of all I feel blessed lucky to be
one of the survivors of you know what
people what my experience was the war on
cannabis right and the repression of our
government so I mean I recall em back in
the mid 70s when we really thought
proposal in California would legalize
cannabis so you know there's some naive
optimism to that kind of view but since
then everyone
virtually everyone that I know that has
survived a long time in this industry
has gone through you know major
successes and you know devastating
failures and I'm just fortunate it's
either good karma or good luck or or you
know blessings that have protected me
when others have fallen so there are you
know tens of thousands of people just
like me I'm I'm really not special who
have you know ended up dead or
incarcerated through this process and I
myself have you know had all of my
assets seized I've had all of the
product that was fronted to me to move
seized I've lost more money in this
industry than many people will ever earn
right and you know when that happens
there you have to have a certain amount
of resilience and a certain amount of
risk tolerance and a whole lot of trust
from a lot of people that I've worked
with who are willing to still you know
believe in me and front me enough
product to rebound you know my most
recent significant defeat is you know
coming up on its five-year anniversary
and I'm looking forward to celebrating
the expiration of that warrant right and
all of my assets and all of my accounts
were seized and you know there's an
extent warrant out so it was hands off
cannabis and hands off any cannabis
products until you know that warrant
expired and I could get now you know
licensed and regulated
I don't consider the new transition as
legalization I really think it's
regulation and taxation and I really
still believe it's unfortunately largely
based on Kent
phobia and propaganda and is inherently
racist in origin and you know it's even
though more recent statistics show that
over 80% of the population in the United
States believes that cannabis should be
legalized in form some form some
restrict it to CBD or medical only but
you know we we have been and are
continuing to move steadily towards an
increased consumption an increased
consumer base a wider distribution and
you know all I've ever tried to do is
bring more better product to more people
at a fair price right so I abhor
violence I don't lie cheat or steal and
I you would be hard-pressed to find
anybody who has been harmed by anything
that I've ever done and yet you know the
government has considered to hound and
harass and pursue me for that endeavor
so from you started off with the war on
cannabis as though your example like you
said is one of so many examples of
people's lives being just turned upside
down in ways that are just it's so hard
to even imagine what it would feel like
to have assets seized or the your
livelihood and the livelihood of other
people the health state the potentially
the medicine that people are getting to
be withheld from them this type of stuff
that is all extremely crazy that it's
been going on for so long and then you
then you went into how that the you you
mentioned how it was a something about
how the the this now kind of like the
transitionary period is not about
legalization but it's about regulation
and Taxation teach us about that well
once again you know the look let's look
back historically for just a minute and
I'm going to tie in the kind of
suffering many people don't even
remember who Dennis Peron
right so Dennis Peron was responsible
for prop 215 which was the medical
compassionate use at Compassionate Care
Act that was passed in the state of
California back in 1996 now prior to
1996 when he successfully you know
sponsored this bill and successfully he
had been involved for years in cannabis
activism in San Francisco and decidedly
in the state of California as well but
most people don't realize that this
diminutive long-haired gay man right who
owned a restaurant and was doing you
know he said he was the biggest dealer
in the Castro district in San Francisco
for probably a decade and he was working
working his cannabis business out of the
upper floor of his restaurant that was
down in the Castro and during that time
when the AIDS echod epidemic
you know seized the population the gay
population of San Francisco with with
alarm and you know people were having
catastrophic illness problems
he began compassionately distributing
cannabis right and in conjunction with
brownie Mary who was giving away
brownies at the hospital to to hospice
and AIDS patients you know Dennis was
largely supplying right the ingredients
that were going into that out of his own
compassion program so from that effort
grew The Compassionate Care Act which
was the first legalization of medical
cannabis in the country right that's
great and Dennis was wonderful at
getting that performed but what many
people don't realize is you know this
man was arrested 26 times this guy went
to court on charges trial six times was
convicted and spent a year in jail and
was shot by the police on two different
occasions in pursuit of arrest or
exercising of warrants right so so this
man suffered he lost his apartment he
lost his business he lost all of his
inventory you know and he still
continued to come up with strategies
that would press the authorities to
redefine the parameters under which he
was he believed righteously providing
access to patients who desperately
needed and absolutely responded to the
medication so he felt you know righteous
that they were entitled to what he could
provide and that he was committed to
providing it now there aren't many
people that would go through losing
their livelihood you know every couple
of years right
in order to pursue that goal but without
that kind of sacrifice and that kind of
suffering arguably we certainly wouldn't
be where we are today right so when you
tap back in the historical roots there
have been people who have stood up and
helped redefine the social policy and
the legal policy of cannabis and many of
us have suffered right financially
emotionally and you know relationship
wise in in the world because of that but
that doesn't mean that we're you know
we're not intelligent articulate
provocateurs right but there are a lot
of people out there in the industry and
I'm not trying to lay a guilt trip on
anybody but that have had easy access to
cannabis throughout their whole life you
always knew where they could get some
always knew that they'd you know they
weren't gonna risk gunplay and and and
and and arrests for them to acquire
their their regular consumable cannabis
right and you frankly take it for
granted and therefore don't realize that
the struggle continues right it's good
enough and it's comfortable enough now
so hey it's virtually done well truth be
told it's not virtually done we have
decades perhaps generations of you know
of progress to be made here and to be
apathetic and passive at this time right
is not respecting Mary Jane right and
being devoted enough to all that she has
done don't recognize enough all of
mary-jane has done for you right do
something for mary-jane right this is a
marriage and Mary Jane has expectations
and she's been you know using and
abusing me like I said for decades
there's there was so much there first of
all the history that you just started
explaining around the compassionate care
act and also Dennis Dennis Peron and the
brownies was brownie Mary Wow it's so
important to know about the leaders in
this industry that brought us a you know
III don't want to offend anybody out
there whose name I'm not mentioning
right I'm still so many more stellar
examples that represent thousands of
people all over the country yes yes
deserve the same kind of recognition yes
yes that's that's a really important
point so there have been lots of people
over the last 50 plus years that have
just went and sacrificed went through
suffering to provide us with the state
that we have today and then you laid out
this very interesting the spectrum we'll
get to the regulation taxation
legalization stuff in a little bit but
you laid out the spectrum for us to
understand it's like either you have
absolutely clear access to cannabis in
the most safe ways possible or on the
other side of the spectrum is this you
have to go through violence you there's
no cannabis available there's all these
different variables that you have to
deal what they get cannabis so yeah with
somebody who generally has access to a
lot of other drugs as well so he's also
crazy when it's not just cannabis but
then you're you want to go for just
cannabis but then there's also like meth
or heroin and all these other things
involved okay why don't you teach us
about that spectrum and also you
mentioned how cannabis is has a long
history of racism we are well aware and
we haven't talked about this too much on
the show yet but just about the sheer
amount of of african-americans black
people that are incarcerated
due to cannabis related crimes and
overall I believe the number was around
over around 60% of all people that are
incarcerated are there due to cannabis
related causes which is absolutely
absurd
so please yeah please unpack well um I
mean the very the early early anti
cannabis legislation when the propaganda
was in sling or was slinging it right
and it was the reefer madness phase in
the 1930s right and that was you know a
racially inspired one of the it was
economically motivated but it was
racially inspired and by that I mean it
was easy to enforce low-level
criminalization on the mexican the
latino and the black community alright
and so the fear propaganda was under the
influence of cannabis these these
otherwise docile and submissive people
become aggressive rapists of our white
women right and so you know that you you
need to have that kind of paranoia about
the effects of cannabis in order to you
know in order to propagate the kind of
repressive restrictions that they put on
it so I mean that's original but moving
forward in history you know cannabis
possession and casual possession on the
street sometimes low-level transactions
and dealing was prevalent in in in the
black and Latino community right and to
the extent it was it was an easy pop
right so if you and and it was easy to
profile people and it was easy to pat
him down and find some portion of
cannabis on them and throw them in jail
right and start them on you know into
the you know incarceration industrial
complex right and that whole monetary
thing and and you know when we when you
think about the 60% of the population
that's in and I think it's for drugs not
just cannabis I think cannabis only
accounts for about maybe forty percent
of the population but you know back at
that time and as I mentioned earlier you
know traditional access
if you're dealing with somebody on a
street corner or in an apartment
building in a complex right the same guy
that's selling weed is selling smack as
smell and quaaludes is sown meth I mean
you know it's a one-stop shop and he's
got everything so the mere fact that you
have to go there to get your cannabis
exposes you to all these other different
drugs and all these other people that
are into all these other drugs right so
yeah but but there was a gateway effect
because you were having exposure at that
point in time right so you know once
again
cannabis use was was prevalent it was an
easy pop on the street if you're a
profile on somebody and just wanted to
hassle them and you know we all know you
know law enforcement has been racist and
repressive all right for a long time and
so we have a minority population that's
becoming the majority target for that
kind of you know unjustified and
disproportionate attack so to the extent
that you know the black and Hispanic
community are still you know a good
proportion of the consumer profile in
this in this country it seems to me only
logical that they should have the same
kind of representative representing on
corporate boards on business boards on
business ownership and licenses
percentages yeah and and the the access
to this industry right should at least
be representative right and open so that
it's it does not replete with hurdles
that especially eliminate this minority
community right there are to be some way
for special business development loans
for instance to be set aside and
incubator programs for people who have
maybe a lot of experience in the
cannabis industry but have never dealt
with accounting and running a business
don't know the first thing about public
relations beyond it's good if all their
customers give them good word-of-mouth
referrals that's been the extent of
their marketing sophistication in the
past and I don't mean to be critical
it's been effective enough so that
they're still there but now as we
transition into an
new generation of open business
practices right we need to figure out
some way that we don't filter out this
portion of our population yes yes and
actually fully actualize them into the
world so okay that was that was really
good let's see if we can go to the next
lily pad as we're jumping as a frog
the next lily pad is let's go to the
regulation and taxation versus
legalization what we're seeing right now
so yes I make the distinction between
legalization which for me means fully
integrating cannabis into our social
practice and our social pattern so that
I my undeniable right to pursue
happiness and health and in my business
sense and wealth right is not you know
unconstitutionally repressed because
there are a bunch of irrational right
fanatical people who have attitudes
right that would like to interfere with
my rights I know now that I'm not a
member of a silent and paranoid minority
right I'm I'm a member of a majority
that I hope will become increasingly
vocal and loud in asserting that just
because there are some people who choose
to remain ignorant right and and have an
emotional response unreasonable
unwilling to look at facts and science
right which I'm happy to use to justify
that cannabis does have medicinal value
it can intervene in a number of
different symptom clusters that we have
it generally contributes to overall
wellness I have a number of not just
anecdotal data to support those kinds of
claims and my right and the rights of my
fellows
to have access to all of those resources
right should not be unduly repressed by
a minority that chooses to remain
ignorant and afraid now that paranoia
that fear and a swaging that fear is an
ongoing anchor right in the sea as we're
trying to sail this ship through the
rocks and shoals of what I would call
legalization right and every time
there's a new burdensome tax right
that's like the current changes right
and and every time there's an
increasingly repressive restriction
right that's not based on reason that's
based on attitude right that throws out
you know another storm that we have to
navigate through but the sea anchor of
trying to continuously ass wage and
reassure the people who believe cannabis
is going to destroy the world right
is is continues to make this approach
this transition one of incremental small
steps right and I'm impatient enough if
you will here at the senior portion of
my life I would like to see this
transformation completed during my
lifetime and the only way we can do that
is if we stop trying to to reassure the
paranoid right that's never gonna work
we just need to make the 60 70 80
percent of us who you know feel we do
have rights to pursue health and
well-being and you know happiness if
that's how we want to choose it with our
cannabis use you know should be able to
go ahead so III get impatient I think
it's time for us to be bold and and it
you know the thing that bothers me the
most is that you know that attitude of
paranoia and what I call canna phobia
right permeates the legal language that
is used to install the regulations and
taxation system and the greed to collect
the taxes and to maximize the tax in
beyond the expense of setting up a
regulatory system right so I don't mind
in the industry the industry should pay
in taxes for the cost of its own
regulation but the regulation needs to
be reasonable
right we have variance limits on you
know cannabis lab tests in the state of
California that are scientifically
theoretical impossible to meet you know
we get so much different variance from
well you know how sunny it is and how
what kind of water supply you had in
what nutrients you used and and every
single one of those things that
introduces new variance into the
determination of the product not to
mention that a sample batch that's
harvested in the field will have
different readings if their top cola
buds or if they're lower you know you
know water leaf buds etc different areas
in the field may have different results
right and so retesting the same product
and not getting a result that's within
10% of the original value should not be
disqualifying it's just recognizing
nature is variable right and you know
bear in mind again and again can't
repeat this often to us and nobody has
ever died from the consumption of
cannabis right so regardless of what
criteria were putting on it now and how
repressive and restrictive they are
right maybe some of them are paranoia
based and not rationally based why isn't
there a medical advisory board to the
Bureau of cannabis control why isn't
there a scientific laboratory advisory
board to the bureau of cannabis control
why isn't there some way for us to
inject scientific fact right into this
process so it has to be recognised in
the way the regulations are defined and
the way that they're enforced right and
you know I I don't want anybody to to
think that I feel entitled right to
impose you know my values but you know I
think we
side of how a government would educate
its citizens on cannabis right right
right now we might be on the leading
edge of coming up with what we're
calling micro dose right products so
these are for people that you know want
to have a little bit more frequently and
control titrating their dosage by their
frequency of dosing right and the micro
dose amounts are small enough so they
escape the parameters of variance in
quality control we don't have testing
accurately enough to consistently tell
us how much microdose is in each
finished package and they won't allow us
to submit a very homogenized sample of
all the ingredient before it's put in
that we can then divide scientifically
by the amount delivered to calculate a
final dosage that's they won't allow us
to do that no not everyone we can
measure and we have to sample every
depending on the different product we
have to sample one every thousand one
every three thousand one every five
thousand randomly selected from the
final package and it has to match the
label content right and within ten
percent and and if it doesn't then it's
failed and ironically it's seized it's
interrupted in the distribution chain
right until it gets retested and
relabeled so as you're speaking about
this I'm getting these you know these
visions of us moving towards more
scientific advisory on the medical side
of the government for the health
benefits and just the legalization in
general of the product also about your
you started venturing as well into some
of the legalization into sorry in to the
regulation and Taxation now within the
regulation these sort of tests that are
happening to make sure things are within
10 percent are also of course you know
it's important to we need
sure that the doses are exactly what
they say for micro dosing especially for
people I don't want to go away too high
and then on the taxation side of things
aren't a lot of the taxpayer dollars
going towards education and towards
other research programs so the taxing is
o is a is okay yeah a portion is going
toward I'm happy to say is going towards
education and research from my point of
view not enough not a high enough
proportion a higher proportion is going
towards enforcement right which which is
like shouldn't surprise us right the
ability of the authorities to monitor
and examine and ultimately repress right
the free access to this product is
embedded in the whole process right tax
where we are hiring and training people
to go out and do blind visits to
dispensaries unannounced show up knock
at the door show their badge get access
and inspect and audit
everything in the shop including review
access of the 90 days of video
surveillance tape that they have
supposedly been collecting on their
facility and they can do that
unannounced at any time they want
right and they can cite you for and they
can they can start by citing the
receptionist with the fact that after
they produced their badge
she didn't require them to log in before
she gave them access to a secure area
and they cite her for that and say here
I'm here with the Bureau of degree of
cannabis control here's my
identification and she doesn't say oh
still you cannot go by here until you
sign again but I'm just saying I've got
I've got dozens of these stories right
yeah so maybe we go on the let's you
know as we're talking about the benefits
of some of the taxation
well maybe talk about some of the you
know the 52 years that went by we're at
a pretty good place even though we want
to get it done before we pass you know
before we're both gone like we'd like to
see civilization adopt this at a greater
level especially the medicinal side of
things what about where are we at now in
terms of things moving forward and then
what are you most looking forward to in
the future what I'm most looking forward
to in the future would be referring my
mother to the board-certified
endocannabinoids who had finished a
medical specialty residency and training
in the endocannabinoid system and having
him be able to combine all the other
previous diagnostic medical data that
had been collected with his own careful
history-taking
and his own diagnosis and use his
mastery of the science to write a
prescription that will have the basic
cannabinoids the THC in the CBD and the
cbn and the cbn cbn and the terpenes
right and recommend two or three
different delivery systems so here's an
edible for you here's a topical for you
here's a tincture for you and here's an
inhalant for you right and explain the
different methods of administration and
absorption and encourage people to keep
track of their consumption initially
until they understand how it's affecting
their overall wellness system and if
they're and I firmly believe that if
there is a you know a sarcoma in
somebody's bone right that it would be
possible to come up with an injectable
form of high concentrate cannabis that
can be delivered directly to the tumor
and will result in significant remission
so I mean I believe all of that is
passed
yeah and I believe that the
endocannabinoid system basically
monitors the other systems of the body
right and brings them into balance
brings them into homeostasis that's why
that's some of the magic of the plant
and the fact that you know a lot of
people don't realize every mammal on
earth has an endocannabinoid system
right and it wouldn't be there except it
responds to the endocannabinoids that we
can deliver from cannabis so in many
ways I think you know it's almost a
divinely inspired complete system that
we're almost completely ignorant of and
as smart as I may sound to some people I
want to let you know I know less than
10% right of the information that's
available and that information is
probably less than 10% of what we really
should know yeah the only thing I know
is that I know nothing yeah yeah totally
totally totally you you started painting
this beautiful scenario that I'm also
was just so loving the vision of in the
future of just being able to work with a
medical professional that is just super
good at their craft and then being able
to properly get don't dose dosage based
on your biomarkers who you are whether
it be a topical or an inhalant or an
edible though that was just a great
example and then do quantify itself to
see how things are impacting you there
just that sounds like the most optimal
scenario of the future and I loved it
and that that's a beautiful vision I'm
really looking forward to that III like
I love that one no one's that's
definitely one of my favorite parts of
the conference so far is that beautiful
vision that you just painted that was
great thanks Mike that was so good that
was so good
do you have something else that comes to
mind that you think's really important
to share as we go you know
I'm sick I'm blessed that I'm frequently
sought from my opinion right one of the
strong mission vision value goal
level strategic plans that I adopt and
that I pretty much require all of the
people that work with me to adopt is
that the cannabis culture is one of
being a socially responsible member of
the community right so you need to give
back to your community and I just mean
geographically where you live I mean the
community of cannabis the community that
needs cannabis policy reform the people
that continue to need donations of your
time and your money and your commitment
to help see this process through right
right right and and you you need to do
more than sit there behind your media
and say oh yeah that's a good idea you
know you need to stop watching this
right now and go and look up
organizations that you can actually
volunteer to be a member become a member
volunteer to help them with whatever
production they're doing and start
sending in their money and then get on
the phone and enlist ten other people as
your cadre to do the same and support
this so that we can get it done alright
so that that that's very important to me
and I and I think if if you are a
company that doesn't isn't willing to
set aside five ten percent of your
annual profits towards policy reform and
community support groups and and you
know lobbying efforts for cannabis
policy reform and education and whatever
you know I don't I don't care what you
do in any of those areas but you that
you do it is very important and secondly
I'm gonna tie it back right back to
Dennis Peron and compassion and where we
came from right there ought to be a way
that we have an untaxed tract of
cannabis production and distribution
through to consumers who have
unfortunately are the victims of you
know catastrophic
or disorder or you know have some kind
of a chronic situation or end our our
indigent and I'm necessarily mean I
don't think you should have to be you
know destitute in order to you know get
get subsidized
access in some way to cannabis saying
that was that out of if there is
somebody that is physically or mentally
ill to a serious degree of their
approaching death their stage four
cancer they're just they need the help
of cannabis as an option then I found it
really interesting envisioning a sort of
like you said non-taxed and a way for
basically the whole world ordered the
United States whichever nations want to
get involved to to funnel philanthropic
dollars into a pool that can then draw
from that pool into getting cannabis for
the person that desperately needs it to
survive long if everybody involved in
supply chain right devoted five or ten
percent of their service free of charge
nonprofit right I'm willing to reinvest
I'm willing to repay you for the cost of
the fertilizers and the soil amendments
and anything out of pocket but you don't
make any profit on this and the people
that do the transportation don't make
any profit on this and the people who do
the concentrating don't make any profit
if everybody makes it nonprofit right
but just covers expenses we can deliver
some cannabis to people at you know I
believe a third a quarter of the price
is currently retail in the market right
that's the sort of loving caring
mentality that empathetic mentality I
love that we love that so I I'm really
happy that you brought that forward the
corporate social responsibility just
just the essence of taking a percentage
of what is being built and in giving it
towards the greater good of humanity
it's really a difference of whether or
not you're in it for the money or you
want to change the world yeah right and
if you want to join me
we can change the world the money will
come yeah and actually there have been
so many success
so billionaires millionaires leadership
spiritual leadership all different types
of leadership from around the world that
has been for the longest time saying
stop doing things for the money do it
because you love doing it every single
day and the money comes and the people
gravitate towards you and that's how the
best the best way do it that is a very
powerful way to wrap things up this has
been very nuanced over the last fifty
two years I love it I love it and we've
only scratched the surface with all the
with all the information but you
definitely gave us really strong
highlights and granddaddy Mike this
really strong highlights really strong
highlight so we really appreciate having
you on the show huge thank you huge
thank you
yeah thanks I run for tuning in as you
all know give us a comment below with
your thoughts we'd love to continue the
conversation join the public telegram as
well also go build go create go manifest
your destiny go and bring that forth
into the world thanks everyone for
tuning in and we'll talk to you soon
peace
[Music]